أولا أشكرك على
الفضاء والحقيقة هي أن ما نحن عليه
ما نراه في غزة هو مجزرة حقيقية
إنها تشكل جرائم حرب
وليس فقط ما رأيناه على أرض الواقع
من اللاجئين جافالينا اليوم الماضي
ولكن ما رأيناه منذ هذا 7
أكتوبر في الواقع يمكننا أن نقول ذلك
وحتى ما يحدث في غزة
ستكون السنوات الخمس عشرة الماضية تأسيسية
من جرائم الحرب لأنها الأولى
العنصر الأساسي بالنسبة لي هو أن
الصراع لم يبدأ في أكتوبر، بل بدأ
75 سنة احتلال غير شرعي إيه
فلسطين أكثر من 15 سنة تحويل
gfa في أ
غيتو حقيقي في سجن حقيقي
لفتح السماء وما نحن عليه
رؤية أنها مثل الحكومة المتطرفة
لقد أطلق اليمين الإسرائيلي العنان للغضب
وحشية على بلدة جافا
إخضاعها بقطع الماء عن الطعام
الاتصالات في العقوبة
الجماعية وذلك وفقا للقانون
الدولية المكونة ل
جرائم حرب، أعتقد هذا
إنه عنصر، إيه، كان واضحًا جدًا
المدعي العام للمحكمة الجنائية الدولية
اه قبل يومين بالضبط في
الحدود مع رافا حيث هو نفسه
يتحدث أيضا عن هذه الجرائم
الحرب وإسرائيل تسمح لنفسها
ارتكاب جرائم الحرب هذه مع
الإفلات التام من العقاب بفضل
إيه الموقف المتواطئ للولايات المتحدة
والاتحاد الأوروبي وأعتقد أن هذا هو الحال
من المهم جدًا إدانة التواطؤ
للاتحاد الأوروبي ودوله
متحدون لفهم بالضبط
الإفلات من العقاب الذي يتصرف فيه
وتعتبر هذه الجرائم جرائم حرب في إسرائيل.
عند قصف المستشفيات
مخيمات اللاجئين والقتل
بشكل عشوائي على القاصرين و
للمدنيين في غزة سيكون هذا بمثابة
العنصر العنصر الثاني الذي بالنسبة لي
يبدو لي هاه
في الأساس ونحن نرى أيضا كيف أن الاتحاد
يحاول الأوروبي إزالة هذا السوء
يتحدث الضمير ونحن نفهم أن كل شيء
وهذا لن يكون ممكنا إذا كان التواطؤ
التابع
من الاتحاد الأوروبي والولايات المتحدة
الذين يرفضون طلب FES إلى النار
نحن نرى بالضبط كيف الحكومات
كيف قطع البوليفي العلاقات مع
دولة إسرائيل، وهذا بالضبط ما
نحن نطالب الدول أن تفعل ذلك
الأوروبيون يعلقون علاقاتهم
امتياز مع إسرائيل لفرض ذلك
وقف إطلاق النار ونحن نرى كيف إيه
تشيلي وكولومبيا تأخذ
قرارات شجاعة بسحبهم
سفراء إسرائيل للضغط
إلى الدولة التي ترتكب
جرائم الحرب الدولة التي تعطي
نفس ايه مواطنيك الذين
لا يهم
اه الرهائن اه ما بداخله
الأبله والشيء الوحيد الذي يبدو هو ذلك
يريد أن يطير بمجموعة النظارات
2 مليون شخص أو نحو ذلك في الداخل
ارتكاب التطهير العرقي الحقيقي
في المنطقة. ولهذا أعتقد ذلك
من الضروري الحديث عن كسر العلاقات
من أ
حظر الأسلحة لا بد من الضغط عليه
لإسرائيل حتى لا تشعر بالإفلات من العقاب
بحيث لا تشعر أنك تستطيع أن تفعل ما
الذي يريد أن يكون قادرا على تدوس
القانون الدولي وأعتقد أن هذا
يكون
من الضروري وضعه على الطاولة
علينا أن نضغط على الحكومة
أقصى السكة اليمنى أولاً لـ
فيصل فو
ومن الواضح الثاني بالنسبة لهم للانتهاء
الأعمال العدائية ليس فقط ضد غافا
ولكن أيضًا ضد الجبهة الإسلامية للأردن و
ومن الواضح أن المركز الثالث سينتهي برصيد 75
سنوات من الاحتلال لأنه لن يكون هناك سلام
المنطقة حتى لا تحتل حتى
فالاحتلال لا ينتهي بشكل عادل
الذي أهل
فلسطين و